CONTAGIOUS DELTA VARIANT SPREADS
FURTHER.
>> Bill: THANK YOU, PETER.
NICE TO SEE ON THE NORTH LINE
THERE.
FOR MORE ON THIS, STEVE SCALISE
IS WITH ME.
GOOD DAY TO YOU.
HERE’S THE NUMBER, MORE THAN 10%
OF THE TRAVELING TEXAS DEMS HAVE
TESTED POSITIVE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> BILL, GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
AGAIN, THE HYPOCRISY, ANY TIME
THAT THERE WAS ANYBODY ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE THAT TESTED
POSITIVE, THEY WOULD
AUTOMATICALLY CALL IT A SUPER
SPREADER EVENT, AND THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA WOULD BE
RUNNING WITH IT FOR DAYS, THEY
CONSUL HE TRIED TO BLAME
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR
EVERYBODY WHO GOT COVID, AND
HERE YOU HAVE THIS EVENT WHERE
THEY ARE LITERALLY FREEING TEXAS
FROM DOING THEIR JOBS, TO HAVE
VOTER INTEGRITY, BY THE WAY.
THIS LIE THAT THE BILL IS TAKING
AWAY ANYBODY’S RIGHT, IT JUST
ENSURES THAT EVERYBODY LEGALLY
ELIGIBLE TO VOTE CAN VOTE, BUT
PEOPLE WHO AREN’T LEGALLY
ELIGIBLE CAN’T VOTE.
EVERY STATE SHOULD WANT THAT.
THESE PEOPLE WERE FLEEING FROM
TRYING TO DO THAT.
AND THEN THEY SPREAD COVID HERE
IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
ULTIMATELY I THINK IT JUST SHOWS
THAT THE DEMOCRATS LIVE UNDER
THIS DOUBLE STANDARD.
THEY WANT TO LIVE BY A DIFFERENT
SET OF RULES, THAT THE RULES
SHOULDN’T APPLY TO THEM.
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA LOOKS THE
OTHER WAY.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE SEEING THIS
FOR WHAT IT IS.
>> Bill: A COUPLE THINGS HERE.
YOU HAVE THE ANTIBODIES, RIGHT
CAN AFFECT MY UNDERSTANDING.
AND YOU ALSO WERE JUST
VACCINATED A FEW DAYS AGO ON
SUNDAY.
WHY WOULD YOU WAIT SO LONG FOR
THAT?
>> YEAH, MONTHS OF JULY TESTED
FOR THE ANTIBODIES, SO I WOULD
IMAGINE MAYBE IT WAS A YEAR AGO
I MIGHT HAVE GOTTEN COVID BUT
DIDN’T REALLY HAVE ANY SYMPTOMS.
BUT HAD THE ANTIBODIES, BUT
ULTIMATELY WITH THIS NEW DELTA
VARIANT YOU ARE SEEING -- I’VE
HEARD A LOT OF HOSPITALS IN THE
LAST FEW WEEKS, AND USING THE
CASES GO UP.
IT’S NOT TO THE ALARMING LEVEL
WE SAW LAST YEAR BY ANY STRETCH.
WE SHOULDN’T BE TALKING ABOUT
CLOSING DOWN THE ECONOMY WHERE
SOME PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO DO
THAT, SOME PEOPLE ARE TALKING
ABOUT CLOSING THINGS DOWN AGAIN.
THAT’S NOT WHERE WE ARE.
BUT YOU DO SEE ABOUT 95-98% OF
PEOPLE IN HOSPITALS AND PEOPLE
WHO AREN’T VACCINATED.
I’VE ALWAYS FELT IT WAS SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE.
I APPLIED WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
DID WITH OPERATION WARP SPEED TO
BRING MULTIPLE VACCINES TO THE
MARKET IN THE QUICKEST TIME
EVER.
BUT IS NOT BECAUSE THEY CUT
CORNERS, THEY TESTED ON
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE BEFORE
ULTIMATELY GETTING THAT FDA
CONDITIONAL USE APPROVAL.
SO IT IS SAFE AND EFFECTIVE.
I TOOK IT AND I WANTED TO SHOW
THE PICTURE TO JUST ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE.
GOVERNMENTS SHOULDN’T BE
MANDATING IT OR TRYING TO SHAME
PEOPLE, WE SHOULD BE GETTING THE
FACTS OUT THERE AND ENCOURAGING
PEOPLE TO TAKE IT.
IF THEY HAVE HESITATION, TALK TO
YOUR DOCTOR.
ULTIMATELY IT SHOULD BE A
DECISION BETWEEN YOU AND YOUR
DOCTOR.
BUT WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
IT IS A SAFE AND EFFECTIVE AND
FDA-APPROVED DRUG, AND FDA IS
STILL THE GOLD STANDARD FOR THE
WORLD.
OTHER STATES, OTHER COUNTRIES
MARVEL AT OUR PROCESS.
THAT IS OUT THERE AND AVAILABLE
FOR EVERYBODY WANTS IT.
>> Bill: AND YOU ARE TEAM
PFIZER, AS I MIGHT COME BACK IN
APRIL.
AND HE FELT GREAT?
EXCELLENT.
QUESTION FOR YOU ABOUT WHAT’S
HAPPENING IN THE SENATE.
LINDSEY GRAHAM SAYS THERE’S A
POWER GRAB THAT HE HAS YET TO
SEE BEFORE IN HIS TIME IN
CONGRESS.
HE IS WITH DOMINIC LAST NIGHT
>> THIS IS POWER GRAB.
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE HAS
GOT NOT A DAMN THING TO DO WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THEY WANT BUT AMNESTY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
>> Bill: OF ITS BIPARTISAN
SPENDING, BUT I DON’T KNOW IF
IT’S GOING TO HAPPEN OR NOT.
YOU’VE GOT $579 BILLION IN NEW
SPENDING, $300 BILLION IN
TRANSPORTATION, AND THERE’S THE
THOUGHT THAT THIS THING IS
FALLING APART RIGHT NOW.
IF IT DOES, THE DEMS GO ALONE.
THEY MAY HAVE A PACKAGE IN
EXCESS OF $4 TRILLION.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT PASSES IN
AMERICA IN THE YEAR 2021, GIVEN
THE STATE OF THINGS NOW?
>> FIRST OF ALL, FOR THE GOOD OF
OUR COUNTRY, I HOPE IT DOESN’T
PASS, BECAUSE THIS DRUNKEN
SPENDING BINGE DEMOCRATS HAVE
BEEN ON FOR THE LAST SIX MONTHS
IS HAVING A REAL EFFECT ON
INFLATION.
IT’S INCREASING THE COST OF
EVERYTHING THE BUY BECAUSE THEY
ARE SPENDING MONEY LIKE CRAZY,
PAYING PEOPLE NOT TO WORK.
IT’S ALL BORROWED MONEY FROM OUR
KIDS AND IT’S RAISING COSTS
WHETHER YOU GO TO THE
GROCERY STORE, AT THE GASOLINE,
AT THE PUMP, AND I THINK PEOPLE
GET THAT.
BUT THEY DON’T WANT TO DO THIS
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE.
THERE’S A BIPARTISAN DEAL THAT
JOE BIDEN HIMSELF WALKED AWAY
FROM HIM.
HE GAVE HIS WORD TO REPUBLICAN
AND DEMOCRAT SENATORS THAT HE
WAS GOING TO SUPPORT A
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE DEAL,
AND THEN WITHIN OUR, PELOSI AND
SCHUMER THREATENED HIM AND HE
PULLED IT LIKE A CHEAP SUIT AND
SAID, OKAY, WE’LL GO DOWN THIS
ROAD.
THEIR BILL AND RECONCILIATION IS
NOTHING BUT A MASSIVE
MULTITRILLION DOLLAR SPENDING
BILL AND TAX HIKE BILL.
THEY WANT TO RAISE TAXES IN A
WAY THAT WOULD MOVE MORE
MIDDLE-CLASS JOBS OVERSEAS.
THAT’S HORRIBLE POLICY.
RIGHT NOW THE GOOD NEWS IS THEY
DON’T HAVE THE VOTES.
I DON’T THINK THEY HAVE A PLAN
TO GET THE VOTES BECAUSE NONE OF
OUR MEMBERS SUPPORT THAT TAX
HIKE GREEN NEW DEAL AMNESTY
SPENDING PLAN.
BUT SOME OF THEIR OWN MEMBERS ON
THE DEMOCRAT SIDE IN THE HOUSE
AND SENATE DON’T SUPPORT IT
RIGHT NOW, EITHER.
SPEAKER PELOSI AND CHUCK SCHUMER
ARE SCRAMBLING.
BUT THEY SHOULD BE DOING IS
LETTING JOE BIDEN FOLLOW THROUGH
ON THE WORD HE GAVE DURING THE
CAMPAIGN, AND THAT’S WORKING
WITH PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE.
HE HAS FAILED IN THAT MISSION TO
DO IT THE RIGHT NOW THAT’S ONE
OF THE REASONS THEY DON’T HAVE
THE VOTE.
>> Bill: I HATE TO CUT YOU OFF
THERE, AND OUT OF TIME HERE.
WHETHER IT’S $2 TRILLION,
$3 TRILLION, YOU NAME THE
NUMBER, YOU DON’T KNOW WHAT’S IN
IT.
BYRON DONALDS IN 30 MINUTES AGO
SAID NEITHER DO THEY, REFERRING